hi in this video I'll be talking about
techniques to detect protein-protein
interaction I'll be talking about
several techniques but at least focusing
on three major techniques which could be
used to detect protein-protein
interaction first I think I'll be
talking about is co-immunoprecipitation
followed by western blot or mass spec so
this process is very useful in terms of
detecting protein-protein interaction in
vivo but there is a limitation I'll be
talking about that so for this process
you need the cell like set or the tissue
homogenate anything from which you want
to be take the protein I mean where you
want to detect that - protein of
interest are interacting with each other
or not and then when the cell has been
alized
in the tube you would be adding the
antibody coated magnetic beads now these
beads would have the antibody of
interest for unknown protein let's say
you want to understand whether protein a
and B are interacting with each other
so this beads could have the antibodies
against protein a because you know in
this solution protein a is present you
want to detect whether protein B is
interacting with protein a in this
solution or not then what would do you
do you intubate it for some time and
then you would use magnetic separation
to get the beads out you would hope by
that time if protein a you know the
protein a would be there so protein a
would be pulled down by the beads now
expectation is if protein B is
interacting with protein K along with
protein a protein B would be also pull
down so in the Lycett we should be able
to detect protein B if we pull down
protein a so from the pull down fraction
of protein a we would take the pull down
fraction and load it onto the chair and
run it in sds-page then we would perform
a Western blot
I mean transferred that jail into
membrane and perform a Western blot to
understand whether the protein B is
present or not and the result looks
something like this
so you can see we wanted to understand
whether protein a interacts with protein
B or not so we need an antibody and the
protein
antibody we have used so we are
confident that we have pulled down the
protein a that is where you can see the
band corresponding to protein a right
then you want to use an antibody and
Team B now this ntp is against protein B
so in this pulldown fraction of protein
a and P B if B is present and they're
interacting with each other then you
would see a band like that and that's
what you see here you see a band now in
the previous Lane you see you have a
negative control like you haven't given
any antibody against protein a so
literally you didn't do any pulldown of
and protein a so even after giving
antibody of protein B you are not able
to detect it right because we know that
only we would detect in this chair
Western blot if we have the protein
interacting with my protein of interest
otherwise we won't find it so the
disadvantage of this method is that all
the time or all the protein you don't
have the antibodies ready and some
antibodies are not very efficient in
terms of pulldown or detection so there
could be problem but overall this is a
good method of understanding
protein-protein interaction in vitro as
well as email people second we'll talk
about east to hybrid system one of the
best method of studying protein protein
interaction in vitro before we start and
I'll try to understand what it's two
hybrid system is we talked about a
little bit of budding yeast metabolism
so budding East has gouging and the
gives gal gene give rise to galactose
when you brush the enzymes which break
down galactose and it is important for
its metabolism and gal 4 is the protein
which kind of helped the transcription
of this chain now gal 4 has two domains
activation domain and the DNA binding
domain so the DNA binding domain is
important for binding to the DNA where
activation domain a domain interacts
with the
polymerase and thereby initiate the
transcription of the Gallo gene however
if the gal gene is not transcribed there
would be metabolic defect in these East
so we have to clone our gene of interest
in expression plasmid so let's say and
we have to like make a fusion protein
kind of thing so here you can see one
protein is now interacting with so this
is our beta plasmid and we know this
protein is there and we want to
understand with this bit which other
fish plasmid interact so there are fish
plasmid and there could be multiple
different fish placement then you know
that if bit and fish interacts with each
other only then the reporter gene
underneath the promoter would be
transcribed and that that is happening
and if they are not interacting with
each other then the gene transcription
won't happen now you have a fist
reporter so normally what happens is
like these yeast are unable to grow
without this histidine so what happens
is like if this bit and fish are
interacting with each other only then
the history Porter would be expressed
and the yeast would be able to grow in
this medium so then you can have a bait
plasmid and multiple different fish
plasmid with the multiple different fish
plasmid you can try to understand
whether the third off protein is
interacting with your pate or not and
this is kind of data you get from the
experiment so you have your bit
classmate and multiple fish plasmid and
in this situation you can see in these
two situations highlighted in red arrows
they're the bait is interacting with the
fish and that is why you can see East
colonies there right in other situation
you don't see East colonies because all
of them are dead because none of them
expressed a history Porter and that is
why they cannot metabolize histidine and
they are not surviving that is the that
is how we can understand whether a
plethora of protein is interacting or
not so here whatever is marked in red
arrow are interacting with each other
these two proteins and other proteins
are not interacting with each other
is a great method but it is limited to
in vitro not in in vivo there is another
good method for in vitro protein protein
interaction which is fluorescence
microscopy mist so this is called
fluorescence resonance energy transfer
in order to do that you need to have
your protein a and you suspect your
protein a is interacting with protein B
so protein a should be cloned in a
vector containing C FB so there a fusion
protein would be produced and protein B
would be a with a vector it would be in
a vector with a yfp so and then these
vectors will be transfected into the
cell line or the tissue electroporated
anything like that and then you check it
in fluorescence microscope the following
things so let's say there is no
interaction between a and B then what
would happen you try to illuminate the
CSP which is fusion with which is fused
with a and you try to illuminate with
434 nanometer life and and you'd get a
emission at 476 so none of the frit has
offered in this situation right so if
there is no interaction no fret but
indeed if there is interaction then then
you B's fret would happen and these two
proteins are close enough for the thread
to happen in that situation if you
eliminate with 434 meter light instead
of getting a emission at 476 nanometer
you are getting a shifted to 526
nanometer so in this situation you can
understand you eliminated CSP but you
are getting a emitted light in a yfp
range so then you can calculate
quantitatively about their kinetics of
interaction so this fret is very
important and useful technique for
detecting protein-protein interaction as
well but the disadvantage of this method
is like most of the cases it is not if
the sensors are not made or a specific
transgenic line is not made it is not
available in in vivo situation so it is
mostly in vitro types
so and also sometimes threat efficiency
is less and sometimes the proteins are
so big or present in a huge molecular
complex so then we get a false positive
result but still these three techniques
are golden techniques for detecting
protein protein interactions both in
vitro and in vivo so if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up and don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you